[Musik]
das jungfraujoch in den schweizer alpen
der bergkamen gilt als dach europas
genau da will ich hin ich werde heute
fast bis auf den gipfel der jungfrau
steigen aber ohne eispickel und
kletterseil ich fahre mit dem zug zum
höchstgelegenen bahnhof europas
auf schienen durch die verschneite
alpenlandschaft davon habe ich schon
immer geträumt
es geht in richtung des berühmten
dreigestirns aus den bergen eiger mönch
und jungfrau und 80 kilometer von der
schweizer hauptstadt bern entfernt liegt
das jungfraujoch auf den letzten
kilometern der vaart überwinden wir mit
der zahnradbahn gut 1400 höhenmeter
es ist die lieblingsstrecke von
zugführer kurt klossner
sie führt größtenteils mitten durch das
bergmassiv 16 jahre hat es anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts gedauert diesen
tunnel durch den ärger und den mönch zu
schlagen
für mich ist heute noch eine sensation
journalisten natürlich noch keine
rettung wollten alles der gehauene
steinmann sieht bohrlöcher man sieht wo
die die noch mit stangen mal drin waren
und so nach einer halben stunde
erreichen wir das jungfraujoch im
inneren des gebirgs kampf auf 3454
metern
der höchstgelegene bahnhof europas 1912
wo die junge frau waren zum ersten mal
die gesamte strecke bis nach oben
heute ist es nicht nur der
höchstgelegenen bahnhof europas sondern
auch die bahnhofshalle mit der
vermutlich schönsten aussicht mich zieht
es als erstes nach draußen von hier
genieße ich den ausblick auf die
schweizer berge und den aletschgletscher
der längste strom der alpen und unesco
weltnaturerbe
[Musik]
eine zugstrecke ins hochgebirge zu bauen
erscheint mir hier wie eine wahnwitzige
idee in einen stollen des
gebäudekomplexes erklärt mir andreas
wyss warum ich damit gar nicht so
verkehrt liege er arbeitet hier seit 30
jahren und kennt das jungfraujoch wie
kein zweiter auch seine geschichte der
bau des bahntunnels war extrem
gefährlich 30 arbeiter sind dabei ums
leben gekommen
damals hat der arbeiter nach jedem
schlag hatte den boden titel klärung
gedreht und dann der kollege wieder
aufbauen und so haben sie die bohrlöcher
sowie etwa 80 cm in den felsen gehauen
und dann wenn das tief genug war konnte
tina mit rein und dann wurde gesprengt
das wetter auf dem jungfraujoch ist
unberechenbar
innerhalb kürzester zeit kann es
umschlagen die jährliche
durchschnittstemperatur liegt bei minus
7,9 grad celsius die für uns diese
aktion ein bisschen nicht in der küche
lag die offizielle kirche über sie
hinter der europa aus auf 3500 meter und
bei extremen wetterverhältnissen dass
sie auf eine polarstation also mit der
kälte dem wind und so ja da brauchst du
entsprechend eine dicke haut
wesentlich gemütlicher ist es im
restaurant christel bei einem typischen
schweizer käse von den geschmolzenen
käse mit brot oder gemüse rainer hoffer
ist für die drei restaurants und
außerdem noch für eine bar auf dem
jungfraujoch verantwortlich jährlich
fahren mehr als eine million besucher
für einen tagesausflug mit dem zug in 80
prozent der besucher vom jungfraujoch
stammen aus asien arabien hingehen china
die mutigen die bestehen käsefondue weil
sie das auch schon mal gehört haben sind
aber gerade die üblicherweise wenn sie
einen japanischen bereich kommen schon
sehr erstaunt was dann kommt so ein
großer topf mit warmen krise ist für ihn
dabei ziemlich merkwürdig bevor es für
mich mit dem zug wieder hinunter geht
will ich noch mal das schönste genießen
die aussicht
wenn man ein bisschen glück mit dem
wetter hat ist es wirklich atemberaubend
hier oben aber ohne den zug hätte ich
sie niemals hoch geschafft
[Musik]